- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys,
and this week on
"The Super Slow Show"
whip out your umbrellas
'cause it's all
about water.
H2O or H2-slow.
That's a stretch,
but I love it.
We're gonna be messing
with fire hoses,
tidal waves,
and then we'll
head over to the pool
for a fat belly flop.
( sighs )
I'm not looking
forward to that.
I'm looking forward
to the pool
just not the belly flop
part.
- I'm looking forward
to the belly flop.
- ( sighs )
You know it's gonna
be me doing it.
I do know that.
( music playing )
Oh, hello.
You've just joined us
having a spot of lunch.
The crew don't let us
eat with them,
so we, uh,
eat ourselves,
don't we?
Yeah, but this is nice,
we have a nice setup here.
Flowers, nice weather.
Yeah.
Let's hear about
the idea I had
for a video.
- Go on.
- Should probably
do it after lunch.
- All right.
- But, um, I'll just
show you actually.
- Stay there.
- Okay, fine.
( music playing )
- ( Dan coughing )
- What do you think?
- Uh!
- Pretty cool, right?
- I was thirsty as well.
- Yeah.
Still haven't finished
my olive though.
( laughter )
Man, so we can have
some fun with that, right?
Uh, for sure,
judging by this.
Uh, I can't believe
you interrupted
my lunch.
Gav: ( chuckles )
Yeah.
You always look so casual
right before your demise.
- ( Dan laughs )
- It's like, "Huh, would you
look at that. Hm.
( water splashing )
Dan: Oh, there goes
the wine.
Gav:  We got you in
the undercarriage.
Dan: You really are.
I don't look casual
anymore, do I?
Gav: No.
This thing does not
mess around, by the way.
It knocked me clean
on my butt there.
Completely knocked
me over.
- So, should we just see
how powerful this is?
- Yeah.
( water splashing )
- ( screams )
- ( Gav laughs )
Hey!
Dan: Look,
you're concentrating on
your aiming there.
- ( Gav laughs )
- Dan: I'm like come on,
I can make it.
That's so much power
in the hose.
- Gav: Ah, yeah.
- Dan: All the way to the end.
- Nailed it. Nailed it.
- ( Gav laughs )
- Gav: Very impressive.
- Dan: And now you're just
getting me annihilated
for no reason what-so-ever.
Or, it takes a while
to turn it off.
Like, there's no need
for me to be soaked there.
Well, this thing clearly
has enough beans
to send you across
the stage on wheels,
but, can you come
at me, bro?
- Here we go!
- ( water splashing )
( screaming )
( laughs )
Are you all right?
- Yeah.
- You fell and I saw
your face vanish.
I took a full load
in the mouth.
I wouldn't be surprised
if something just went
all the through you
and shot out the other end.
I think I got a colonic
irrigation...
- ( Gav laughs )
- all the way around.
Shall we watch it back?
Absolutely.
Dan: I look ridic--
I look like Ernie
or something,
Bert and Ernie,
( laughs )
like a Muppet at this point.
Gav: It's like your eyes,
nose, and mouth
were scrunched
into the middle.
- You've got full middle
face again.
- ( laughter )
Is that what we're
calling it?
Middle face
is when everything
wants to be by your nose.
Yeah, I'm full middle face
Muppet mode.
You're just straight
into the nut sack again!
- ( laughter )
- Gav: I'm trying to hit
you centrally.
It does look epic though,
doesn't it?
Dan: Yeah, I'm like,
I'm gonna get you.
Gav: ( laughs ) It's like
going through your shirt
- and up out of your collar.
- ( Dan laughs )
- Dan: Oh!
- Gav: In the mouth.
Dan: Oh, right in the face.
Gav: In the face.
I just saw your head
disappear into whiteness.
You just vanished.
I couldn't see you at all.
Whew, that's some lovely
fire hose action.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that video.
Feel free to subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys,
and we will see you
in the very next episode
- of "The Super Slow Show"
where we might be dryer.
- Yeah
But no guarantees.
Hopefully I'll be
dry by then.
It'll be a nicer day.
Eh.
( faint splashing )
- Come on!
- ( laughs )
Well, Dan,
it's begun.
How often do we usually upload?
Once every three weeks?
If that,
once a month maybe?
Why don't we try
16 a month?
So, 16 times
as much work.
- Pretty much.
- Seems reasonable.
Make sure you subscribe
if you don't want
to miss it.
- That is a lot of work.
- That's a lot of work.